so today elliot paige tweeted out
that he will be playing
victor hargreaves in the next season of
umbrella academy changing from vanya now
this would seem to indicate that vanya
is going to become a trans man um and
then retroactively mean that
he was always a trans man now first
thing i want to say is
at the point that we left off in season
two we are actually in an alternate
timeline so it's distinctly possible
this is an alternate version of vanya
and not the vinya we know but either way
it still absolutely works i'm just
throwing the possibility out there and
while i am very happy for this and i
would always want uh elliot page to do
what feels best and most appropriate for
him there is part of me that kind of
would have liked to have seen him
continue to play vania if only to dispel
the notion that trans people have to
play exactly what they are otherwise is
dysphoric but it's not his
responsibility to do that and i'm very
happy for him i'm excited to see it